- The fact that there has been
no accountability with regards
to the whole COVID debacle.
But the other example
that comes to mind as well
is there's been no
one held accountable
for the debacle that was the
withdraw from Afghanistan.
And I'm sure we could come up
with a shortlist very quickly
of other major disasters
of zero people being
held accountable.
No one was held
accountable for the lies
that they told around
the Hunter Biden laptop.
You know, we could
go down the list
that goes to the
heart of your point,
which is so, so important.
We as voters get to hold our
elected leaders accountable
at the ballot box, right?
That is our primary way of
being able to make our decisions
about who we hire and
fire in those positions.
It is up to us to
hold their feet
to the fire to bring
about that accountability.
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Ruben,
and joining me today is
the host of "The
Tulsi Gabbard Show",
a former US congresswoman from
the great state of Hawaii,
and now a former
Democrat, Tulsi Gabbard.
Welcome back to
the Ruben Report.
- Nice to see you, my friend.
It's been a little while.
- It has been a
little while, Tulsi.
This is my first
interview of 2023,
so you really gotta
bring it today.
I know you're busy.
I'm on it, I am on it.
- You're doing your
Tucker thing all the time,
but I know you gotta you
gotta bring it for me.
Can you do that?
- No, I'll do my
best, I'll do my best.
- Let's start real quick.
I don't wanna belabor the point
with leaving the Democrat Party,
and you've obviously
talked about it quite a bit
and I was kind of
trying to nudge you
in my own way for a while.
Is there anything you wanna
comment on related to that?
At this point, you left,
you campaigned with
some Republicans.
Obviously the wave
didn't happen,
but we are seeing
sort of wholesale
changes on both sides right now.
Anything as we start the
year off on that front,
that's on your mind?
- Yeah, sure.
You know, as I think
back to when I announced,
I left the Democratic
Party in October 11th,
and I listed out some very
specific and clear reasons
why I made that decision to
leave the Democratic Party.
What's wrong with
today's Democratic Party
and my decision to become
an independent, and frankly,
the things that we have
seen play out since then
and are continuing to
play out, unfortunately,
just further highlight
and underline those
very real concerns that I have.
And frankly, since
making that announcement,
I've heard from a lot of people,
maybe some people who
are well-known names,
but just also a lot of
just everyday Americans
who have expressed
how they have felt
or are feeling
the same frustrations that I am,
and that they were grateful
to have somebody actually
voice those in a way
that a lot of folks
across the country heard.
So, you know, there's
a lot happening
as you know very well,
Dave, below the surface.
That doesn't make
it into, you know,
the big headlines of the
mainstream media at all.
But it really is this
underlying frustration.
And frankly, it's not just
with the Democratic Party
as we're seeing happen now.
It's with the Republican
Party as well.
And frankly, it points to
just the American people,
pissed off, frustrated
and disenfranchised
with those who are
in power. Period.
- What was it like
for you when you,
because you basically
made the announcement
and then you started
campaigning with some people.
I mean, when you were
going to these rallies,
obviously people liked having
you there and all that stuff,
but you do have some differences
with traditional Republicans.
Was there tension
there or, I found-
- There was no tension.
- That people just get over it.
- Yeah.
There was no tension.
And I think it was,
and sometimes those,
that statement was made, well,
we're not gonna
agree on everything,
which we're not,
who actually does,
but all of those
candidates that I went
and supported that, none of
that was planned beforehand.
And my phone just started
ringing off the hook,
coming from different
candidates across the country
who recognize exactly
what we just talked
about is that there
are a lot of folks who,
whether they identify
as independent or not,
are independent minded people
and who are maybe struggling,
especially in those last
weeks before the election
about trying to decide who
they wanna cast their vote for,
given their
frustrations with people
in both political parties.
And so that was
where the requests
I got came from, frankly,
it was Republicans.
There were, there
were no Democrats,
I think, who had the courage to,
even those who I know agree
with my same frustrations
and concerns with
the Democratic Party,
didn't have the courage
to step up and actually
say those things.
So the request I got
came from Republicans
across the spectrum of
the Republican Party,
and regardless of
differences on other issues,
ultimately I chose to
go out and support those
who value freedom
and who are committed
to the Constitution
and who recognize
the need for leaders to step up
and lead and speak the truth,
whether that is about leaders
in the Democratic Party
or the Republican Party,
but actually step
up and speak for
and fight for the
American people.
- Does that seem like sort of
an obvious extension of the way
that your campaign when you
were running for president sort
of ended in that you
were the last one?
Besides Biden, everyone
else cut the deal,
whatever they had to
do to get into the,
what would be the
future administration?
You stuck and fought,
you didn't cut the deals yet
Hillary Clinton literally
claiming you were in
essence a Russian operative,
so that where you sit today
as an independent
seems fairly obvious.
If you really kind of-
- For anybody who's been
paying attention, right?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I mean, I've always been
an independent minded person,
you know, for as
long as I, you know,
chose to become a
democrat back in 2002
when I first ran for State
House here in Hawaii,
because at that time I was drawn
to the Democratic Party,
because, especially
here in Hawaii,
I saw a party that was really
rooted in inclusiveness,
in civil liberties and
standing up for free speech
and diversity of thought
and the big tent party.
And frankly, there
were a lot of voices
in the Democratic Party
that were voices for peace.
That's changed almost
wholesale since then.
But from that point throughout,
as long as I've been in and
out of politics since 2002,
I've always been an
independent minded person,
always really done my best
to try to make decisions,
policy decisions or
otherwise based on how well,
what's in the best interest
of the American people,
what's in the best
interest of the country.
- So let me ask you one
that's actually
purely on policy,
because I mentioned
to my locals community
this morning that I was
having you on today,
and basically my
audience loves you.
Even even the people
that are say more
right than you are,
they say, okay,
well we can have an honest
conversation with her.
She's trying to talk about
this stuff, all good.
The one that keeps
coming up with you
is they still are
afraid you are going
to come after their
guns if you were
to go back into government.
That they see as
somehow the piece of you
that is still a Democrat
or something like that.
I'm honestly not
even totally sure
of your policies on all of that.
So I just leave it to you
to answer their question.
- Sure.
I've always supported
the Second Amendment
and the right to bear arms.
What I will say has changed
over the last few years is,
you know, previously I, you
know, growing up in Hawaii,
we have one of the
most restrictive laws,
one of the most states
with restrictive laws
in the country as it
pertains to gun ownership.
It takes weeks to be
able to go and apply for
and get a permit
and actually be able
to take the firearm that you
purchased home with you.
It's a pretty tough
and rigorous process.
So I didn't grow up
around, you know,
shooting a lot of guns
and a different culture
than maybe a lot of folks have
in other parts of the country.
And so, as I looked at what
I felt were common
sense policies around,
you know, making
sure that we can try
to prevent mass shootings
in schools and so forth,
that was what was
informing my judgment
and my decision making
as a member of Congress.
The thing that has
changed in a very,
very impactful way
for me is seeing
how the danger of this,
of anyone in government
overstepping their boundaries
and violating our rights
and really understanding
in a visceral way
our founder's intent to
put the Second Amendment
in place, was not only to defend
your safety and your family,
protect your family against
those who seek to do you harm,
but also for us as a people,
as a line of defense,
to protect ourselves against
a tyrannical government.
And when you look at what
has happened since 2020,
in so many respects,
we see more and more
authoritarian leaning decisions
and intentions
and policies being
put forward by our own
federal government.
And you start to see again,
why the Second
Amendment is important.
That's what I started to
see and better understand.
There were a number of
things that happened.
There was the Supreme Court
decision that was made
with regard to the New York
concealed carry permit case.
I read, actually
read through a lot
of the comments and the remarks
that went on throughout that
case, and also the decision.
And there were some things
there that provided for me
some fundamental
insight and caused me to
look at the Second Amendment
in a way that frankly
I'd never had, and very simply,
which is the Second Amendment
must be protected as strongly
and fiercely as we protect
the First Amendment.
You don't have to
get a permit to go,
and I don't have to go
to get a permit to go
and stand on a street
corner with a megaphone-
- Not yet.
- And start yet telling
people what I think.
Not yet, but that
exactly is the point.
That exactly is the point.
Is we are seeing
this infringement
on our right to free speech.
We're seeing people in
very powerful positions
in our federal
government pointing
to the fact in
questioning, well,
I don't know if the First
Amendment is relevant anymore.
I don't know that
it is necessary.
And frankly, people who
are even saying like,
it shouldn't exist in
order to protect people
from what they call
so-called hate speech
or for people being offended
or whatever the case may be.
And then again, for me,
seeing these policies,
these statements,
this kind of direct undermining
of our fundamental
God-given rights
that are enshrined in
the Constitution further
highlighted and really
brought home for me
in a way that hadn't
happened for me before,
with the importance of
the Second Amendment
and why it says our rights
shall not be infringed.
- Is that why, you know,
when you're a guest
on Tucker or now
you fairly often guest host,
that that alignment
makes sense to you
because even though if you
would've said five years ago,
well, wait a minute,
here's a Democratic
congresswoman from Hawaii
and here's Tucker
Carlson, you know,
basically in the
Trump camp, let's say,
there's a reason that
it makes sense now
because so many
people have woken up
to all of these
infringements on our rights.
Like, is that basically
the genesis of what kind of
brings these orbits together?
- I think that's one of them.
I think that there are,
the more people see,
and I think a lot of people saw
it through the
COVID restrictions,
people who maybe weren't
even involved politically
or don't really pay much
attention to a lot of things,
or never watched Tucker's
show or maybe yours
or didn't pay attention
to me or whatever.
I think more and more
people were like,
well, hold on a second,
these decisions are
causing my family
and my community to suffer,
my small business
to fail and so on.
But it doesn't
really make sense.
These are not
science-based decisions.
These aren't decisions that
are actually respecting
our civil liberties
and freedoms.
And really, it just
got to the heart
of the fact that we had people
who got a little bit of power
and decided that they weren't
gonna let it go and
started abusing that power
and making decisions
that were more
about themselves and their power
than it was actually
about helping people.
And so I think there were,
and a number of different
contributing factors to that.
You see people who are
frustrated by corporate America
abusing their power at the
expense of working people.
You see, I think you, you know,
you see impingement on religious
freedom in this country
and also policies
this administration
is putting forward in
different parts of the world.
So I think there's a
lot of different factors
when people look
at, well, hold on,
what are the
fundamental principles
this country was founded upon?
And are those who took an
oath to support and defend
the Constitution actually
fulfilling that oath?
And I think people are seeing
more and more that we have
Democrats and Republicans
in power in this country
who care more for themselves
than they do for the people.
And that's where you see
a lot of folks from across
the political spectrum,
I think coming together,
putting aside the
political labels
and just saying, hey,
this is not right
and this is not what
this country and our
principles are all about.
- Is that sort of what
stops you from just saying,
hey, I'm a Republican
at this point,
because you just feel like
it's just like an old game.
So what's the point, really?
'Cause most of the things
that you're saying,
they do line up more
with Republicans.
I get Republicans usually
fail on those things,
but at least it's the
stuff that they talk about,
which really the
Democrats just simply
don't talk about anymore.
- It's not, frankly,
it's not something I'm thinking
about, being an independent,
I am continuing to do
what I have been doing,
which is to speak the truth
and to call it straight,
whether it's Democrats
or Republicans.
I think that there
are, obviously,
I've been very clear in
outlining the problems
that I've seen with
today's Democratic Party.
If you look at today's
Republican Party,
especially what's playing
out right now on CSPAN,
I think there's probably
a lot of Republicans
who are asking,
well, what does the
Republican Party stand for?
And like you said, one example
is on the issue of
civil liberties,
there are different factions
within the Republican Party,
people who might say, yes,
we stand for freedom
and the Constitution
and civil liberties,
but these are the very same
people who will stand up
and defend all of the
egregious provisions
within the Patriot Act that
undermine our civil liberties.
We see the pro-war machine,
uni party in Washington,
leaders in both
political parties.
I will say there is a glimmer
of hope on the Republican
party side because unlike
the Democratic Party
where there apparently
are no voices now saying,
well, hold on, we should
exercise restraint.
We shouldn't be going and
trying to get ourselves
into new cold wars
and nuclear arm races
and nuclear war with
other countries,
at least on the Republican side,
there's a small
but growing number
of elected leaders in Congress
who have the courage to
stand up against the military
industrial complex and the
war machine in Washington
and their own leaders in
their own party saying,
this is not good for
the American people.
This is not good
for our country.
So, you know, I think
it's most important
for us to look to holding
leaders accountable
from both political parties
and actually try to bring
about that systemic
change that brings us back
to the Constitution, not just
in words, but in reality.
And also brings us back to
what I think is the most
important premise
that our leaders
should use when making
these decisions,
whether on domestic
or foreign policy
is what is in the best interest
of the American people.
What is in the best interest
of ensuring the
safety, security,
and freedom of the American
people in this country?
- Are you worried that
just too many people
don't believe that
that could happen?
So, you know, if
you were to look at
the 1.7 trillion spending bill,
and we're gonna defend the
borders of Oman and Jordan,
but not our own borders,
that at this point there's
been a certain black pilling,
at least at the federal level,
where people are just like,
it just does not work, period.
As I say on my
show all the time,
I live in Florida
where everything
is highly functional and
competent and decent.
So I have a very
weird disconnect
between my day-to-day
life and sometimes
the things that I'm
talking about on the show,
because here it's
freaking working.
Maybe we can export
some of that,
but I think a lot
of people feel,
they look at a bill like that,
they look at the
amount of people,
well, I guess I'll ask
it to you this way.
Would you have voted
for that freaking thing?
- I would not, no, I would
not have voted for it,
there's no question in my mind
for a whole host of reasons.
But that bill is,
I think it's right that that
bill and all that it represents
is something that is at the
heart of this whole debate
around who the next
house speaker will be.
I think some of the problems are
that we're seeing
play out is that
I don't know that
the, you know, again,
I'm not in those rooms at all.
I'm not privy to private
conversations at all
that are going on there,
but what is being reported,
it doesn't seem like
the peripheral changes
that they're talking about
in those negotiations
are getting to kind of what
the heart of the problem is.
And so, you know, we'll see
how that all shakes out.
But I think that some
of the issues raised
by people like Congressman
Chip Roy are important,
and those are not necessarily
issues that are owned
by, quote unquote,
Conservatives or Republicans.
I think there's a lot
of people in the country
who just look at this
from a common sense
perspective and say, well,
no, it doesn't make
sense for, you know,
congress to pass this
1.7 trillion bill.
That very few, most,
I would say didn't
take the time to read
and look at and
actually analyze.
- Zero, I'm pretty
sure we can say zero.
You signed a couple of
these type of things, right?
Like, nobody read
this thing, right?
- No, plus you get
what, barely 72 hours.
Like, not even working
hours, like 72, I guess,
clock hours before you actually
have to vote on this thing.
And oh, by the way,
there's no open amendment,
so you can't, you know,
as a member of Congress,
I would not have been able
to go in there and say,
I have problems with these and
these and these provisions,
and then offer an amendment
on the house floor.
They stopped allowing
that a long time ago.
There's no actual
open opportunity
to debate what is in the bill.
So it just goes to just
how broken the process is.
I think you started
the question by asking,
you know, is it too far
gone, basically, right.
Can it be fixed?
I think as messy as it is,
what we're seeing happen,
play out now with this
house speaker question
is the kind of thing
that needs to happen
in order to start bringing about
the changes that actually
fix what's wrong.
- Yeah.
And just for the record,
we're taping this
on Friday afternoon.
I think they're in their
12th round right now,
and a few people did
switch to McCarthy,
but we're posting
this on Monday,
so Lord only knows
what'll happens-
- We'll see what happens.
- With the rest of the votes.
I wanna back up to something
that you said earlier,
sort of about the
bureaucratic state
and the people who failed us
and did trample on
our civil liberties
during COVID and all that.
What do you think, if
anything should be done?
I'm not a particularly
the type of guy
that wants to have
retribution against people,
but it seems to
me that the people
that forced the vaccines
and the mandates,
and now we're finding out
all of this stuff about,
you know, heart problems and
a litany of other issues.
Nobody's been fired at the CDC,
nobody's been fired at HSS.
Fauci did, I guess,
resign in effect, but-
- Was allowed to retire, right?
- Right, was allowed to retire.
Wilensky is still wandering
around the capitol,
like, what do, should
we do anything?
Do we need to do
anything otherwise,
to me it's just like,
we'll just endlessly,
we'll do it all over again
because nobody will
have paid the price.
- I agree.
I agree.
The fact that there has
been no accountability
with regards to the
whole COVID debacle,
but the other example
that comes to mind as well
as there's been no
one held accountable
for the debacle that was the
withdraw from Afghanistan.
And I'm sure we could come up
with a short list very quickly
of other major disasters
of zero people being
held accountable.
No one was held
accountable for the lies
that they told around
the Hunter Biden laptop.
You know, we could
go down the list
that goes to the
heart of your point,
which is so, so important.
We as voters get
to hold our elected
leaders accountable at
the ballot box, right?
That is our primary way of
being able to make our decisions
about who we hire and
fire in those positions.
It is up to us to hold their
feet to the fire to bring
about that accountability
in kind of the,
you know, the security
state in some elements,
the bureaucratic state,
the administrative state,
whatever you wanna call it.
Congress plays an incredibly
important role in that
with an administration
that fails to hold its own,
both appointed
leaders accountable,
as well as those who are
bureaucrats in the system.
This is where the House of
Representatives and the Senate
come into such a critical role
and why we have this
co-equal branch,
why who we vote for in
those positions matters
so that the oversight committee
can do its job, so that
it can bring people in,
so that they can establish
select committees
to actually hold those
responsible accountable,
and with transparency
to the American people
about what they're doing, why
they're doing it, and frankly,
exposing the dangerous
situation that we have now
where we have these
unappointed unelected people
in positions of power
making decisions,
changing rules
within the government
that have a very real
impact on our lives,
the lives of our
kids and families
and businesses
across this country.
But somehow they're
allowed to essentially
make law through
administrative rule changes,
again, without any kind
of legislative process,
without any input from
the American people
through our elected
representatives.
- Do you think that some of
the other Congress people,
when you were serving, they
kind of liked that fact,
they liked the fact that their-
- Of course.
- That their decision making
was outsourced and basically-
- Absolutely.
- They didn't have
to do anything.
I mean, that's, yeah.
- Yeah, because what
answer do they have though
when they go home?
Maybe they have a
town hall meeting,
or they answer their
constituents like,
well, why has this happened?
Like, oh, sorry,
it's that guy's fault.
Sorry, it's their fault.
No, this didn't go
through Congress,
it's not on our plate.
But in reality,
they're abdicating
that very essential
and important responsibility
that Congress has.
And it has happened over time in
so many different aspects
of our government,
and it allows people
who we as voters elect
to basically sideline themselves
because then they
carry no responsibility
for those decisions
that are being made.
Congress should be fighting
to claw back their
own power, right?
Congress should be bringing,
trying to bring that back,
roll back the power
that's been given
to the executive branch
to just basically do
whatever they want.
But unfortunately, again,
and this is, you know,
who's responsible,
well, guess what?
Both Democrats and Republicans
have been in charge,
you know, one way at
one time or another.
And we don't see that
kind of the recognizing
kind of what's the
underlying issue here?
And instead we see a
lot of leaders or people
who are in leadership positions
just reacting and saying, well,
we'll just pass a
new law for this,
pass a new law for that,
but not actually getting to,
well, how did we even get
here in the first place?
And let's get back to the
cause of the problem rather
than just throwing
another bandaid on it.
- So to that point, you were one
of the most outspoken
anti-war congresswoman,
congresspeople in the
country while you served,
and you paid the price for it.
I mean, literally, again,
Hillary was calling
you a Russian stooge
or whatever they were
saying about you,
because you were anti-war.
So right now, with
this Ukraine situation,
we are not at war.
Congress has not declared war,
but we are funding a war
to over a $100 billion
at this point, another
40 billion just
in in the 1.7 trillion bill.
We're funding a war.
We're giving weapons,
we're giving intelligence,
we're training soldiers.
To me that kind of
sounds like we're at war.
- It essentially is a proxy war.
And this is a yet another way
that this administration
and Congress,
Democrats and Republicans
in Congress have once again
bypassed their
constitutional responsibility
if they want to go
to war with Russia,
which they've made very clear
that that is what they want,
both directly and verbally
and also indirectly
through their actions,
make your case,
make your case to
the American people
about why you feel that
that is so important.
Why they feel it is
in the best interest
of our country and
the American people,
and why the American
people should be willing
to pay the price for it.
As you said,
it's already over
$100 billion dollars.
Meanwhile, you look
at a lot of folks
who are still struggling
and suffering here at home,
both those who have been
impacted by natural disasters,
those in Mississippi,
for example,
who are still under
a boiled water policy
because they don't have access
to clean drinking water that
they can use for their families.
I mean, there are so many basic,
basic challenges here that
we are too often told.
We just can't afford it. We
don't have the money for it.
And yet we, the
people have had no say
in this a $100 billion
that's gone over
to fund this proxy war
with Russia via Ukraine,
not to speak of the suffering
of the Ukrainian people.
So what do we do,
I think is the big question
right at this point,
because we all have
great compassion
for the people of Ukraine.
What Putin did is wrong,
absolutely wrong in
invading Ukraine.
These are not disputable things.
The problem is that
we have politicians in
Washington and the Biden
administration as well
as in Congress, who,
even though they say they
care for the people of Ukraine
are not doing what is necessary
to bring about an
end to this war,
instead seeking to escalate
it further and further
and doing so through their
actions, which again,
really just shows their true
motives, true intentions,
which is feeding into the
military industrial complex.
It's not about
bringing about peace.
Because if it were
all the way back
in February and in March,
and in subsequent months since
they would've been supporting
a peace process rather than
actively trying to block it.
- Were you shocked
when Zelenskyy
gave that speech to
Congress a couple weeks ago
and in essence said-
- Yes.
- There will be no compromise.
I mean, it's a
little odd to say,
and I agree with you on the,
first off, we as locals, we
had an office in Ukraine,
we had to move our guys out.
We've gotten some of them
to the United States,
but some of them are
in Macedonia right now.
Like I have complete
sympathy for everyone there.
But the guy that's in the
war shows up here and says,
I will not compromise
with the guy with nukes.
And everyone applauded.
It's like, do you
know what happens
when the guy with nukes
thinks he's losing?
- Exactly, exactly.
There there was so much
that was deeply disturbing
about that speech
and how most members
of Congress reacted
with applause,
with adoration,
treating him as though he
is some hero or rockstar.
I think one of the things that,
in addition to the
point that you mentioned
about we have actively,
and I hold our
leaders responsible.
Zelenskyy is gonna do what
Zelenskyy is gonna do,
but I hold our
leaders responsible,
President Biden and
Democrat Republican leaders
in Congress responsible
for the decisions
that they have made that
have put the American people
and our country at
risk by escalating
this war against a
nuclear armed power,
pushing us to the brink
of nuclear catastrophe
with no plan, with
no investment,
saying, okay, well here we are.
Good thing we went and
invested trillions of dollars
in underground bunkers
for every American citizen
to go and take shelter
because we've put you
in this situation.
They've not done that at all.
If anything, they've
done it for themselves,
but not for the American people,
which leaves us in a position
of perish in that scenario.
But the other thing in addition
to that was so disturbing
about his speech
was how he spoke about freedom.
And he spoke about democracy,
and he's not only putting
himself in the position
as being this champion of
democracy around the world,
but our own leaders
have lionized him
and made this whole war about,
well, we have to
defend democracy
and freedom in Ukraine
or else democracy
and freedom in the world will
be assaulted or attacked.
Well, let's look at what
kind of democracy Zelenskyy
is leading in Ukraine.
You know, he not only jailed
his political opponents
very, very, very early on,
he banned their entire
political party.
You know, there are so
many different, you know,
he shut down any media
that was not controlled
by him and his
government, essentially.
So no free speech, no room
for any political opposition.
And then he went after religion,
no religious freedom
in this country.
He shut down the second
largest Christian
Church in that country.
And for what?
Under the guise of
democracy and freedom.
How is this representative
of the kind of democracy
that our founders envisioned?
It doesn't.
And so what I reflected on,
and what I think every American
should think about as
they watch this is the guy
they have put as the
figurehead of democracy.
And we saw Republicans
and Democrats cheering
and applauding for this person
who doesn't believe
in free speech,
doesn't believe in
freedom of religion,
doesn't believe in freedom
or democracy really at all.
And so we should not
therefore then be surprised
if this is what they
believe democracy is,
then we shouldn't be surprised
at the kinds of things
that they're doing to undermine
our own freedoms here at home,
and our own democracy
here at home.
Because it's happening.
It's not a question
at this point.
And this should be
alarming for everybody
and not surprising that this is
the direction that
they're taking,
which is not representative
democracy at all.
It's more representative
of a dictatorship or an
authoritarian government.
- Yeah.
And the funny part is,
I don't blame Zelenskyy for
coming here and demanding money
and demanding no compromise,
because why the hell not?
And then you walk away with
everything you asked for.
So he's doing what
he believes is right
for himself or his
party or his country.
And you've got a bunch of
people here that are like,
oh, how much can I
write on that check?
- Exactly.
Exactly.
And that's the thing
that's so crazy to me.
Even after that speech,
I think it was a
couple of days ago,
there was a story that
popped up where Zelenskyy
was basically saying that
his quote unquote allies
have no excuse not to send him
these light armored vehicles.
There's no excuse why
they aren't just sending
him exactly every single
thing that he demands.
That's crazy to me.
And it's crazy,
what's even crazier
than his demands though,
is he knows what power he has
because he has the
most powerful people
in the United States of America
bowing to him and giving
him whatever he wants.
And President Biden essentially
ceding our country's
foreign policy decisions
to this guy in Ukraine.
You know what, when people
ask President Biden,
"Well, when does this war end?
When do we stop?
When is enough enough?"
And he says, "Well,
you know, we're in it."
I'm not gonna quote him directly
'cause I don't have the quote,
but he basically has said,
"We'll do whatever it takes.
We're in this until."
What, this is up
to Putin to decide?
Like what about your leadership,
your responsibility as the
president of the United States?
What about the leadership
of the head of the house,
the head of the Senate,
from both political parties,
where is their leadership
and their responsibility
come in to play?
Because they are
certainly not serving
the best interests of
the American people,
our security in our country
with these decisions.
- So with that in mind,
if we were to flashback to say,
you know, what is it,
about six years ago we sat
down for the first time
at my house in LA
when you were running,
it was just at the
beginning of the campaign.
- Gosh.
- And it seems like-
- Time flies.
- It seems like many
lifetimes ago, right?
- Yeah.
- It's many states ago for me.
You were obviously
frustrated with the squad,
and I think you were one of
the first at least sitting
Democrats to talk
about that publicly.
Like a lot of online people
were talking about it,
but you were
frustrated with that,
but then that thing went
rampant throughout the party.
Do you think there's any who,
like, is there any
calm voice there
that's saying anything
that makes sense
to Biden or Kamala or
it just is gone now?
- It's a good question.
I don't know really, frankly,
I don't know. I don't know.
I know that there
are people there
who I worked with before
who take a more common sense
approach and who are concerned
about a lot of the same things
that I'm concerned about.
But whether or
not they actually,
whether or not they have fallen
into that same wave
of so-called wokeism,
and whether or not they
actually have the courage
to have these conversations,
even in private,
even if they're not willing
to say these things in public,
even in private, I don't know.
But what we do know is
how they are carrying
themselves publicly,
the things they are saying
publicly and the decisions
that they're making in
the votes that they cast.
And the fact that
we don't have people
in the Democratic Party today
who are speaking
out against things
like infringing on free speech,
standing up for free
speech is not a thing
in the Democratic
Party anymore today.
Or if you say something that
is offensive to anybody,
then you shouldn't
be allowed to say it,
which is just insanity.
You know, I don't know
if you've had Ira
Glasser on your show,
but he, as the former head
of the ACLU for decades,
and who's somebody
who considers himself
a very left progressive
person, is to me,
the lone voice that I've heard
in those political circles,
who is calling out this
insanity for what it is.
'Cause he's literally
lived through it
and he has seen what happens
when you carry through,
when you carry out some
of the policies that,
or the proposals that
they're putting forward
that actually limit our
First Amendment rights.
And unfortunately those
voices are very, very rare.
- Yeah. I actually,
I haven't had him on,
but I had his predecessor
I think was Nadine Strossen,
and when I had her she talked
about how the ACLU used
to defend the rights.
I know you know this,
the defend the rights of Nazis
to march in Skokie, Illinois,
where they had more
Holocaust survivors
than anywhere in
the United States.
That was once the ACLU,
the defender of free speech.
So that's actually a good segue
to the big tech stuff,
because you've been fighting
the big tech stuff
for a long time.
And actually during
your campaign,
I think you were in a lawsuit
with Google at the time.
- Yeah.
- So A, did anything
come of that?
And B, then just broadly
like Twitter files
the whole freaking thing,
what is going on here?
- The whole freaking thing.
I judged throughout.
So for those who don't know,
I filed a lawsuit against
Google because frankly,
of their interference in our
elections through my campaign,
it was something that I
experienced personally
when I was first
running for president.
I knew there were
a lot of people
in this country who
didn't know who I was.
And I hoped that, you know,
by going and standing on the
presidential debate stage
as people would see,
hey, who's this person?
She might be saying
some interesting things.
How do we find out
more about her?
So we set up a Google
Ads account in the hopes
that people would start looking
to try to get more
information about why
I was offering to
serve as president.
Well, that happened,
I was the most searched
candidate in that first debate
and in subsequent debates after.
But in that first debate,
what ended up happening
afterwards is Google suspended
our ad account without
any explanation,
without any warning.
Our tech team obviously
got on it right away
and they were trying
to figure out,
okay, what did we do wrong?
How do we fix this?
How do we bring
this account back up
so it's not suspended anymore?
Didn't get a response.
And then I don't know
how long it was later,
but finally the
account was reinstated
without any
explanation whatsoever.
So obviously this had
a very negative impact
on what I was
trying to accomplish
in my campaign and being
able to reach people.
But we filed the lawsuit
for the deeper issue,
which was if Google can make
this decision single handedly,
whether it was somebody sitting
at a small desk somewhere
just making that
decision themselves,
or if it was people
at a higher up level,
it doesn't really matter.
The point is that you
have this monopoly
and this major
massive tech company
that has the
ability to interfere
with the information
that voters are seeking
to get about so that
they can make a decision
about who they wanna vote for
in the most important
office in this country,
the most powerful
office in this country.
And so if they could do
that to a sitting member
of Congress running for
president of the United States,
just imagine what they
could do to anyone,
anywhere, for any reason to
serve their own interest.
And so that was the
crux of the lawsuit.
We filed the lawsuit,
a judge tossed it out.
But as we have seen now in those
years since there have been
more and more
revelations coming from
and about these different
big tech companies,
how they have directly
sought to undermine
and interfere, frankly,
in our democracy,
not to speak of all
the censorship stuff,
that's a whole other
parallel conversation.
- So when you see the
Twitter files get dumped,
and now you've
already gone through
this as you just laid out.
- Kudos to Elon Musk for that.
- Right?
Absolutely. Absolutely.
I mean, here's one guy,
all he's saying is,
hey, free speech.
And of course now we're watching
the entire machine call him
a white supremacist
and god knows
what else they're
saying about the guy.
But when you watch all
of this get exposed,
is this another case of, okay,
well a certain
certain amount of us
that have believed this
stuff was happening
now are strengthened
in our view,
but that the rest of the
machine just ignores it.
So we showed something
on the show last week
about how ABC, NBC and CBS
nightly news in the first week
of Twitter files did
literally zero coverage.
- Wow.
And then over the course,
then they added in some
cable news channels except
for Fox, and it turned
out to be like 17 minutes,
you know, over the course of
two weeks, something like that.
But leading to this just sort
of bifurcation of the populace
where I can't blame
all those people
who don't know
what they don't see
because they have no
idea what they don't see.
- Right. Right.
- We do with that?
- That is exactly
the whole problem.
I think there's a
number of things.
First of all, new
media platforms
are becoming more popular
and more important,
especially as people
are maybe even if they,
they don't know what
they don't know.
But I think that most
people are recognizing
that they can't trust
what they're being told
on these mainstream
media platforms.
And so for those who
have time and interest,
they're able to look
for other news sources
and it's awesome to see
how new media is growing
and providing really
substantive platforms
that can help feed that
desire for real information,
for truth, or
frankly, a different,
you know, differing opinions,
real dialogue and conversation.
I think we also, again,
have to look to Congress,
look to the power
that big tech has.
It's not by accident.
You look at how much money,
big tech dishes
to both Republican
and Democrat leaders
in Washington.
You can very clearly
connect the dots
about why Congress has not
done anything at all, frankly,
to be able to reign
in these monopolies
that exist in big tech
that directly
undermine our democracy
and directly interfere
in our own elections.
I think those are kind of
the two places
that we start with.
- All right.
So assuming that maybe
we do some of that,
but do you think it just ends up
as another one of the, what
we talked about before,
like just nothing changes
because the machine operates
in a certain way, right?
- I guess, you know,-
- You could see I've
been like slightly
taken this black pill at
the federal level lately.
Life is good in Florida, but
I definitely have taken that,
you know, to some extent.
- I get it, I get it.
I remain hopeful, Dave.
I remain hopeful and
I refuse to accept.
- Good, I want hope,
I want hope by the way.
- We need it.
- Yeah.
- I refuse to accept
that this broken system
is just the way it will be,
and that we, the American
people, have to accept failure.
The system is broken, it
does need to be fixed.
There are wholesale changes
that need to be made.
But I remain hopeful
that the more people
who learn about this,
the more voices there are
that are speaking the truth,
lifting up the message
of how important our
God-given freedoms
are in the Constitution,
that we have to stand up
against those who seek
to try to undermine
them and take them away.
We, the people in this
Democratic Republic have
an immense amount of power
if we choose to use it,
both at the ballot box
and with our voices.
We saw, unfortunately, again,
how many people did not show up
to vote on election
day in November?
That's a travesty.
If we're not showing up,
if we are not invested
in our own future,
then how can we
expect anything really
to be fixed or changed?
And we'll see the
same, most powerful,
most wealthy people
continuing to run the show,
not for us or our benefit,
but for their own.
- So as we see
that split in like
in the reality that
people are experiencing,
we're also seeing a split
in where people are living.
You know, something like
500,000 people since COVID,
I mean, it's a crazy number,
have left California,
Florida has an influx
now of almost 400,000.
New York has lost about
300,000 Texas gained.
We're just seeing this
movement happening.
You happen to live in a place
that is separate geographically.
So yeah, Hawaii,
even if it can be
a little tough there sometimes,
I guess with some
of the politics,
it's like you got the waves,
I know you're doing
okay over there,
but what do you make of this
sort of geographic shift
that's happening
across the country?
Because ultimately, it obviously
will make the red states redder
and the blue states bluer.
I mean, Hochul only won
by five points, Hochul,
whatever her name is only
five points in New York.
But if you factor in
about 350,000 people
that left New York,
it's like, wow,
it maybe could have gone red.
- Yeah. Yeah.
I think it shows that, again,
through the last few years,
how much state government
and leadership has an impact,
and you're seeing
that kind of exodus
and movement happening.
And I think it points to kind
of one of the bigger changes
that I think will even be harder
than some of the ones
we're talking about.
But that needs to happen,
which is the federal
government needs to go back
to what our founders envisioned
as being fulfilling
the response,
the limited responsibilities
of the federal government
and empowering states to lead
and implement their own
policies at the state level.
Because every one of
our states is very,
very different in so many ways.
That was the picture
of this country
that our founders envisioned.
But unfortunately at
the federal level,
there has been just over time,
more and more of
overreach and stranglehold
on power disempowering
the states.
And so hopefully with
some of these changes,
people are recognizing more that
that responsibility
at the state level
is where those decisions
really need to be made
in so many respects.
And frankly, a lot of governors
also we've seen over
the last few years
standing up and saying,
no federal government,
we're not gonna do exactly
what you tell us to,
we're not going to just
bend the knee and comply.
We will uphold the
oath that we took
to fulfill their
responsibility to the people
of their state as well,
which I think is encouraging.
- So I take it when you see a
guy like Ron DeSantis keeping
the state open and getting
woke stuff outta schools,
and from at least
where I sit, you know,
pretty much doing
everything right,
that's the type of
marker you have for hope.
- I think I'm not tracking
everything happening
in Florida politics,
but I think some
of the decisions that we've
seen played out nationally
that he has made for
Florida, it shows that,
you know, he's
making the decisions
that he feels are best
for the people of Florida,
and a lot of people
are moving there.
So it seems to be working.
- So, you know, I have to
ask you about the future.
What's the deal?
Are you enjoying these.
- I think the audio,
I can't hear you.
- I can tell clearly
that you're enjoying
the stuff you're
doing with Tucker
when you're guest hosting.
It's just, it comes
across on television.
Like you really are
enjoying it, obviously,
and you're doing your
podcast and obviously
you're speaking and you're doing
some campaign stuff
when it arrives,
but do you wanna get
back into the machine?
Are you relieved to not
be part of that right now?
Is it all way too early?
Is it just the most
annoying question on Earth?
- Well, it's not the
most annoying question,
it's just one that I don't
have an answer to, frankly.
To me, the question
is not about,
well, do I want to get
back into politics or not?
Because I have never
thought in my mind like,
oh, I'm setting out
on a political career.
That's never been
a factor for me.
The question for me
that I've always had
and continue to reflect
on and try to answer is,
where and how can I
best be of service?
That's my goal.
And so whether
that ends up being
in an elected
political position,
or if it ends up
being in a position
where now I'm trying
to use my voice
and whatever platforms
I have available
to me to be a voice for truth
and common sense and
freedom in this country,
when a lot of people are
afraid to speak the truth,
a lot of people are not
focusing or maybe don't know
about what is actually happening
in our country that's
undermining our freedom.
So that really is the answer
to what happens next for me?
Do I get, you know, run
for office again or not?
Is I don't know
the answer to that.
I will continue to seek to be
where I can best be of service
and make a positive impact
for the American
people in this country.
- Tulsi, you continue to be
on my very short
list of sane people.
I wish it was a longer list,
but you're on the short list.
I'd like, like to see your
shortlist of sane people.
I hope I'm on that list.
- Of course, of course.
And it is,
it's unfortunately a
shortlist of known people,
but I know that we
are in good company
of people across this country
who may not have
a show themselves,
but who are hungry for and
yearning for some common sense,
courageous leadership
in this country,
and that that is what
we desperately need.
- On that note, I welcome you
to the free state of Florida
whenever you wanna come.
I know our waves
are not as good.
That's the thing.
- I'll be there in
February actually,
I'll send you my dates
and hopefully we can
hang out a little bit.
- Dinner on me.
It was good seeing you.
- All right, sounds
good, thanks, Dave.
- If you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlist all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.